esta zona industrial abandonada fue
transformada en un vertedero ilegal
[Música]
este pequeño océano de desechos se
encuentra a tan sólo 20 km de parís y
justo al lado de un espacio natural
protegido
hay de todo de todas partes
hay tuberías materiales de construcción
llantas carrocería poliestireno no
sabemos qué pasará con esto miren cómo
se está rompiendo royal de cómo se hace
fin de touré cohete este vertedero
ilegal fue creado entre el verano de
2019 y la primavera de 2020 cuando gran
parte del país estaba confinado
alfombras tarros de pintura colchones
aislantes toneladas de desechos fueron
arrojados aquí un equipo de voluntarios
se puso en acción vestidos de rojo se
autodenomina en la brigada ecologista
buscan en la basura con la esperanza de
encontrar a los responsables
lo que hacemos es tratar de encontrar
documentos números de serie que nos
ayuden a rastrear todo esto
todas las pistas son fotografiadas
una vez que los documentos son hallados
en el equipo los envía a las autoridades
locales a veces incluso se ponen en
contacto con las personas mencionadas
para entender cómo sus documentos
acabaron acusación forma dónde mismo
probablemente viene de una mudanza los
de la mudanza no se molestaron y lo
tiraron es culpa de la pobre persona que
se nombra aquí son contratistas
independientes empresas de mudanzas que
no quieren pagar un verdadero legal
desechan la basura donde sea
el objetivo de la brigada es preparar un
caso legal para que los fiscales locales
se encarguen de la situación la
autoridad local cerró el acceso al
vertedero ilegal donde los residuos han
empezado a pudrirse lo que preocupa a
algunos
hay agua subterránea acá el agua seguirá
por todas partes y tal vez es la
terminemos bebiendo después
la autoridad local no ha fijado una
fecha para la limpieza de las miles de
toneladas de basura que costará millones
de euros
al noreste de parís se volvió hay un
vertedero ilegal invisible los camiones
vierten los residuos de construcción en
estos campos que son en parte propiedad
del gobierno local y luego los entierran
como se muestra en este vídeo un
empleado de una empresa cercana fue
testigo de ello
como nos
deshacemos
downtown tiene un tallo
todavía se ve algo de basura del campo
miren acá
eso es chatarra es para hacer hormigón
armado así que obviamente son residuos
de construcción no deberían estar aquí
esta mañana físico
una investigación legal ha sido abierta
a este otro campo en la misma zona
también se le dio este uso a sólo unos
metros de las viviendas la tierra fue
excavada y la basura incluye llantas y
barras de acero para reforzar concreto
entrevistamos al alcalde de bollullos
quien fue interrogado durante la
investigación no
no no
no no estaba al tanto si lo hubiera
sabido habría detenido el vertido
inmediatamente me enteré cuando la
policía quiso hablar conmigo feliz con
su última condición y
muchas personas han sido interrogadas a
raíz del escándalo incluido el antiguo
director de los servicios municipales en
2020 más de un millón de toneladas de
residuos fueron vertidos ilegalmente en
el campo francés